[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the lobby
games spots weekly hangout here at 2
p.m. Pacific we kind of thought dannyel
DWI might still be in the intro video
it's a Bittersweet episode it is our
first without the great dannyel DWI he's
gone on to do new and exciting things
and we wish him the best but the show
most go on so I'm Mike Mah Hardy I'm
your host now and I'm here as often is
the case and will often be the case is
Peter Brown I am still here yeah and
your beard is much less bushy than I'm
used to yeah it was pretty big it was
getting it was getting up there but I
got a lot of hair on my head it's
weighing me down it's more than me and
Rob hamler hey what's going on uh I
can't really grow a beard so I feel like
I comment on Pete's too much just beard
Envy I love it um we're going to have
kind of a long episode today there's a
bunch of smaller segments we're going to
get through um but yeah so stick around
I guess you'll know when it ends but
uh anyway we're gonna start with
Bioshock remaster which is out this week
I guess there's 2K is calling it a
Bioshock celebration or something what
anniversary is it is it an anniversary
10th yeah 2006 Bioshock sure yeah maybe
that was the occasion but it's on 4 Xbox
One um I guess we're talking about like
bioshock's Legacy kind of because people
have not talked about Bioshock enough at
this point um I think you guys are both
fans of the series yes political
commentary environmental storytelling
and Rand and Rand an Rand and Rand yeah
it's uh I think the general consensus I
don't know still like maybe you guys
would disagree I still like the first
the most out of all three the first hit
me the hardest yeah uh and I actually uh
was late to the game I mean I played all
three but but um having been so when
uh when BioShock Infinite was like being
teased and like on its way to become
released I was like oh I got to go back
and play these so I played them all in a
row and man that first one like had such
great twists in the story uh just that
world was so engrossing um yeah I mean
that that's it was definitely one of my
favorite games all the way through that
game too like the ride was like for real
like I don't know you know so many
movies or games and anything you agree
on is like oh there's a drop here I
didn't feel that way at all with that
game like all the way through yeah it
was like a really impressive uh like
collection of set pieces put underwater
which was kind of Novel at the time like
we hadn't seen a lot of that but then
you coupled it with this whole big daddy
little sister thing for me that was the
iconic experience of the original game
that just still sticks with me and I
kind of I mean I guess they they didn't
wear it out but they they sort of it ran
its course so I understand why it didn't
continue uh into Infinite uh but yeah
that's really what stood out for me that
was like a pretty imp the the moral
choice was so real right and uh yeah
yeah you had the twist the would you
kindly twist which I guess I won't spoil
if you don't know it by now but it
doesn't really it it's you know marked
for kind of being the one that you know
as like actually looks at like what it
means to play games which you want to
get really deep into it but still like I
played it I think two years ago again
and I haven't played the remastered
version on PS4 or anything but it still
holds up really well on how it feels
like it's it's still a little jarring
cuz there's not any auto aim which we're
so or maybe there is like that minuscule
one to help you but it's very very kind
of unforgiving if you're not accurate
obviously you can use plasmids and
whatnot in addition to uh just
conventional like 1940s 50s weapons but
it held up like really well from what I
played um and obviously two you return
to Rapture uh two is the one that I like
not to be contrarian but I actually
think I like it more than a lot of
people you contrarian prick yeah it was
way different um thanks for shrugging
off the insult just continuing yeah it
was way different right it it I mean it
had that horror feel feel to it where
you know already there's like chaotic
splicers right is what they call them
all around the world but then you know
you have this it's big sister right the
the the one that stalks you the whole
time that every aspect of that character
was was terrifying the noise you knew
when it was about to come after you it
would kick your ass uh you felt like you
were constantly on like uneased like
throughout that game yeah the really
cool thing and kind of disappointing
obviously the big sister shows up at set
moments throughout BioShock 2 the
original plan um was to under 2K Marin
was to have her this like persistent
threat that wasn't scripted kind of like
if you played uh res Evil 3 Nemesis the
Nemesis God randomly will bust through
walls and doors screw that and it yeah I
mean that makes that game a novelty but
I almost wish they hadn't like shered
that and just kept that if they made
like to the one where she's constantly
chasing you you're just like almost
always worried about your wellbeing even
more than than you already were I
thought that would have been a cool
design conceit that sounds pretty cool
thinking of it in the same terms as
Resident Evil 3 cuz the Nemesis was
definitely a game changer in that regard
for that Series yeah yeah and and like
manura Den's probably one of my favorite
dlc's in general um the team who like
two of the members uh on full bre
company who did gone home they're
working on Tacoma they did manous Den
Steve Gainer was the lead designer it's
well worth playing just I BioShock 2 is
well worth playing just to play a
nervous Den but in terms of gameplay
BioShock 2 was different in way you
could uh you could do like the Skyrim a
power in one hand a weapon in the other
as the Big Daddy which was really fun I
think it's kind of underrated in terms
of gameplay and I thought it actually
flows really well from like one combat
situ situation to another and how you
combine weapons and how you use the
powers to supplement them I think that's
like one thing the game doesn't always
get talked about I think it's just
overshadowed by the first BioShock I
didn't play BioShock 2 but I know the
conversation around it is sort of like
yeah it's the lesser of those first two
games what what was how did it fall
short in a lot of people's eyes I I
think it was just the the story was
almost like felt like it was lingering
in Rapture too long and they didn't
really make use of the fact that it was
cool that you were a big daddy cuz in
the first game you Dawn the Big Daddy
armor later on right and it slows you
down and it was kind of cumbersome from
what I remember like a moment or two
right it was it was like a chapter if
that but BioShock 2 I feel like it's
very fun game I just don't think it
changed things up enough to Warrant this
hanging around in Rapture uh giving you
a glimpse at like this world that you
know Rapture the first one was
interesting because you're fig F out why
it crumbled and like you're kind of
seeing it happen in the process as well
um BioShock 2 it had already done it was
just just decrepit underwater city and
it wasn't exactly didn't really seem to
be going anywhere the whole time
although it is really fun from moment to
moment um and then obviously 2013
BioShock Infinite rolls around and it's
totally different you're in Columbia the
flying you're in the sky you're in the
sky yeah you go from uh what What's the
gungan city called in Phantom Menace
don't I was waiting for someone to do
the comparison I had to throw it in
there yeah well like their rebreathers
that they wear yes I I was a huge fan of
that game despite the phantom menace no
I said game I know jerk there there was
a game whatever um yeah I actually
really like that game I mean visually I
actually like enjoyed that game a lot
and I and I felt uh it kind of
got overshadowed with like you know the
the themes of like racism and all that
stuff like I mean that people really
didn't like that um I found it really
interesting all the way through and I
thought the twist at the end was was
freaking crazy that was that was a game
where like I personally would put so
much time I think also cuz I played like
it in like two sittings like I just went
nuts on that so yeah oh yeah it was like
I just went nuts I really well was it
was I was laid off at when I was at my
last job and I had nothing to do
memories for J or play
Bioshock Let's Escape and so yeah it was
like two three settings and um man like
that twist like had me thinking for a
couple days it was one of those moments
like you know there's movies and and
games in your life where you just like
can't stop thinking about it and I even
was so frustrated with that ending that
I immediately and it frustrated in a
good way it was just like a really like
curveball for me I I was so frustrated
was like I want to see it I want to play
it again I immediately started playing
again realized I probably shouldn't and
should go eat or something like that but
I just wanted to see you know all those
um find money all those motifs and
foreshadowing things from that from that
game all the way through since you know
in the first few seconds they were doing
stuff like that and I thought that was
just really great but visually too it's
it's a stunning game yeah especially for
its time I'm assuming you played it as
well Peter I did I never ended up
finishing it but I but I definitely
really liked what was there um the it
was impressive to me how they could sort
of make the game feel like Bioshock but
have it in such a different setting with
all of that Mobility stuff thrown on top
I thought that was really rad I like
those sort of mechanics and games uh and
it just married really well with
bioshock's style of shooting yeah um so
yeah I can't remember why I didn't
finish it I got pretty far into it
though and I definitely liked it yeah I
don't is like the statute limitations on
spoilers up yet or no
like probably not I I don't want it is a
cool twist I don't want to ruin it for
if there are people the remasters out
this week if you haven't played it go
play it I think it's well worth it right
it does it gets gruesome as you can see
right here oh my God noting yourself on
fire yeah uh it get right away when you
first get the Skyhook and you jam in the
guy's neck oh it's wild yeah and it just
starts spinning in his right right right
right like jugular uh yeah no these I
actually the one complaint I have about
like pacing wise or you know like actual
gameplay I felt too overpower toward the
end maybe I was just playing a normal
difficulty but by the time you have all
the different uh they're not plasmids I
forget what they're called in this uh
tonic right right change the name yeah
and by the time you have like I know
Mary just the other day when she was
here was saying she just spammed murder
of crows that one shoot crows at people
uh I like the there's like an earthquake
one I think I don't know but then yeah I
mean I I understand that and yeah you
could definitely feel that way that's
understandable but I mean if I'm doing
crows all day I'm going to get bored
right you got to change it up sure the
thing that actually uh in that game I
remember getting tired of was the
element of you taking down those giant
blimps oh yeah was that like toward the
I think like three of the way that was a
big fight toward the end it's like it
was just really repetitive and it felt
like it was kind of half asked but um
yeah in general that was a very unique
game compared to that franchise I
respect them for changing it up so
heavily you know like how what can we do
different let's take this guys the world
was weird though cuz there was like a
Coney Island area it was kind of like I
don't know
1940s Brooklyn almost when the people
lounging on the beach and whatnot it
delved into some like things in terms of
like racism and then also like there you
like no Irish people allowed in these
bathrooms it just felt very very much
like that era of America like fear of
immigrants and whatnot wasn't there like
some high society like party scenes like
infiltrate and I actually thought those
were pretty cool masquerade kind of
things yeah yeah I thought it mixed it
up way I I don't know I liked it I
thought the world itself was super weird
in a great way and I think yeah The
Logical direction to go after Rapture
was up uh or maybe I guess theological
Direction I don't know I'm not an
architect of Sky cities but um yeah I
don't know you guys do you have any
intention of returning to those well
okay so if you didn't have like 90 other
games you need to play and getting ready
to play 90 other games and traveling to
China and Japan like you are would you
return to these if you could or do you
not have any interest yeah no I'd
actually really like to I think it's
been long enough and I never gave
BioShock 2 a shot so it'd be fun I'd
like to yeah I might yeah i' you know if
I were to pick one I would probably
start with one again I mean of the three
right it's like the most notably
different and and you know is somewhat
modernized I guess you say uh start at
one and see how you feel you know uh I I
would still like to see do two again to
be honest like I kind of forget those
moments with big sister but I remember
like being frantic and like running
around and stuff and I yeah I just
remember enjoying that element yeah
definitely I think i' I kind kind of
always want to play all those they just
feel too great I love that vein of uh
like the Looking Glass Studios vein of
game like DSX kind of not like uh DSX uh
System Shock like now Dishonored has
like Bioshock influences kind of those
first person shooter but much more
measure paced to it and like almost
Adventure aspects but yeah that's
Bioshock remaster collection uh tell us
in the comments below if you feel plan
on playing either of them or I guess any
of the three in the near future uh tell
us what your favorite is tell us why you
don't like one or two or remastered and
uh yeah cool tell us what your dad's
like yeah tell us everything a long list
of things to tell I just want to know
well my dad yeah Bruce Brown he's 70
Brown Bruce Brown that's sick it's
aeration still writing about tech oh
yeah I remember you telling me this he's
prolific Tech writer at his elderly age
um anyway Halo 5 Guardians has a new
update uh on both consoles and PC but
most notably on PC because Forge comes
to the platform or came to the platform
with Windows 10 uh as well as custom
games so you can essentially play like
landan games on PC now which is the
first for the series sure I mean online
right sure on um yeah we Mary and I uh
did a stream last week um before the
release we got like an early copy which
was nice um but that game is cool man
like I'm excited to see where it goes I
mean it's you know it's Halo 5
multiplayer free on PC MH that's like
kind of wild in itself uh the only
problems being that you know you're not
getting experience you're not raising
your uh level at all but you're still
enjoying the game in every aspect as far
as like the um actually to separate from
you can't you can't do war zone or or
any of the other other uh a few other
types of game modes I believe you can
just do like basic Team battles 4v4
right orx no eight on eight okay eight
Okay cool so 16 players um but what's
exciting to for me is when I got to have
hands on with it and actually mess
around with the forge stuff because
again like I you guys have seen it in
like on Reddit and all these places of
these gifts of these player made Forge
maps and they're freaking incredible the
amount of time people are putting in
revamped their whole Forge system to
make it easier you know you're adding in
what's called prefabs which you can
share prefabs being like I make a base
myself I just put it up and it's like
the speed and and the intuitive nature
of it is so freaking quick we were we
played probably like I don't know two
dozen Maps uh in the span of the stream
that were all player made and you could
make your own so I could take a prefab
and bring it down so I don't have to
spend the hours on end making a Bas it's
really great and I'm actually really
excited to see
how well it does cuz I I would imagine
it would do well uh mouse and keyboard
control really great for you know making
maps and everything um yeah and then you
know and here's the other thing is John
Luke here actually showed me um there's
like a subreddit to for Destiny because
one of the problems being hey say I do
not have Halo 5 on Xbox I don't have any
Xbox Live friends that's a problem how
am I going to play multiplayer I got to
find people in order to join a fire team
what's cool is that despite them making
a update soon that they said they're
going to make a custom matchmaking
ability which is huge you can still
right now uh go into subreddit and just
find a fire team there are tons and tons
of people who are like hey you want to
play Let's friend up just join this and
uh Jean Luke was saying he was playing
like all week on all weekend long
playing these awesome fors well that's
what what Titanfall 2 is implementing
with networks right to extend the
longevity of or the I guess the lifespan
of a multiplayer shooter which drops
considerably which this is what the
ninth update or eighth for Halo 5 nth
right Anvil's Legacy yeah and obviously
like a big point of uh the update is is
Halo 5 like worth returning to now
whether on consoles especially obviously
on PC it's the first chance you'll have
on PC but I don't know does have their
updates been doing a good job of drawing
you back in I know you you're playing
periodically and you and I do streams
every once in a while yeah I I
definitely put in a couple hours
whenever I can uh for each update um
it's it's a back and forth thing I
definitely enjoy it um I don't know what
to say I think I I think it's mostly I
think I just need friends to play with
maybe to I'll be I don't I don't have
any friends yeah um but you know they
add new maps they add new weapons so
it's fun to try out those like they
added a new uh ship called The Wasp
that's really fun to use is it just a
rich white person you fly around on well
at the end of the day yeah I mean what
oh you let me rephrase like in in the
sense of the acronym wasp
Oh Oh I thought you insinuating like
microtransactions oh like I should just
roll that Segway yeah with cards and
stuff that you can buy yeah um I don't
know there's something about those cards
that is so is so unappealing to me like
every time I finish a match it's like
open this pack Boom Confetti look at all
this and then you get into the menu I
got to open them and then I I'm just I'm
sick and tired of constantly seeing
numbers of like how much it takes and
then money and and the money thing is
just killing me with my transactions in
my face and I I just find that
frustrating I don't know but there's
that that but in general it's a fun ass
game and I'm more inclined the updates
are great and I actually think they do a
great job of of delivering those people
are who are huge Halo fans have have
respected that however I'm more into
this forage idea I think this is going
to take off they are really setting a
nice groundwork for some Community
involvement and there's already been one
now it's ever so going to grow like it's
exciting to me I mean you've seen the
maps just to touch on the maps that like
you've seen right like um trying to
think there's one I mean people have
made we went to 343 recently to do kind
of a feature on this and coming to
Windows 10 and they weren't allowed to
promote Forge with other properties
content but they showed us like uh
someone had made an Endor map like tree
houses kind of in the walkways uh the
intro they did a whole intro catic with
R2-D2 and uh they showed Vader burning
they put a Spartan like a black Spartan
on his back and uh and had flame so it
was really great so oh sorry the funeral
py yeah yeah so as you know in Return of
the Jedi there's like that what's that
don't don't do this Vader and he's like
you know it's lug looking over Vader and
his and his you know his helmet's
charred up hel like this finish someone
like recreated that whole thing and it's
hilarious like that's your intro to like
the match well you can control the
cameras and what not for people unar
with Forge yeah so he made a he made he
put Mist in it's indoor trees with
platforms and you're flying around is
hilarious it's hilarious har said he he
customized his own assets sure well he's
got like R2-D2 one shot and then it's
like Vader dying you know what up Star
Wars right and then a bunch of Spartans
leaping between tree houses and uh kind
of falling off a lot but there was yeah
there was a giant foosball table which
um they said you know like a big point
with the mouse and keyboard controls now
is you have much more fine tune control
over the level editor itself you can uh
actually change the mathematics of like
man Cannon so you can do a 45 degree
angle as opposed to like a 35 mhm for
example uh but the Foosball table I
don't understood how it worked but that
was also made in like 4 hours by someone
on their Halo 5 QA team that had never
worked with Forge before uh so that's
why it was appealing to me I haven't
gotten the chance to play it much I know
you did a stream last week I believe you
know the game wasn't even released yet
there was all this stuff already
available I just think it's going to
really exponentially grow um and the
other thing too is there are these
devoted fans and just imagining 16
people just like frantically working and
building these elaborate Maps yeah and
now with the ability to just drop in
some guy made a like a star destroyer
just drop that in like pod racing right
some guys like hey I have all the pod
racers that are hooked up to ghosts they
don't they don't drive that well but
make your own map and you know recreate
you know episode one pod racing from 64
now this is Halo 5 that's right yeah uh
so I I'm excited for that stuff one
thing I do want to touch on that the
chat has kind of been saying jokingly
but I it might be worth talking about uh
so they're making Microsoft's making a
big push for Windows 10 uh I think Gears
of War altimate Edition was the first
game and then you know from here on out
if I'm not mistaken uh every Xbox One
game or every Windows 10 game you buy
will be you'll have it for free on the
other platform uh or maybe it's Xbox One
to PC to Windows 10 so play I think
recor is the very first game where it's
Cross by okay so where you buy it you
get it definitely for both platforms I
think for Gears you could you had to
like buy it on both but you could cross
save or something like that yeah yeah
and from what I remember yeah cuz that
was when we did the re-review of the
game but yeah if I'm not M you were
saying last week that the Halo 5 the
update on PC is kind of tedious and
people are wondering if this is just a
half-hearted attempt to bring people to
Windows 10 even more it's Windows 10
unfortunately it's you know it's it's
got some bad rep which we've all seen
pop up on our PC at one point or what
was surprising to me was that you had to
opt for the anniversary edition update
um which does
not do anything sign Ely worse or
anything bad to your uh operating system
but it still required a EXT like my home
computer is not all that great
especially especially with internet
speed but it took me like two hours to
download this anniversary update um but
again I mean I don't know I think I'm
pretty sure like I don't know I think
your your computer can be opt in to
already like you may already have the
anniversary update is what I found out
later it just depends on like whether
you have that unlocked in your update
settings on your PC I don't know either
way it's bigger than just like a
firmware patch for your a driver patch
for your graphics card I mean it's a
whole update for an OS just to get this
game to play sure yeah and it's not that
great I mean I'm not saying that's like
just brush past that idea but it's still
worth saying that like I don't know
they're making a cool push for for Halo
forge namely um but yeah it's your
choice if you want to do that update or
not I mean I don't have any problems
with it yeah hopefully you know like
Halo 5 will have a little more blood in
its veins until we get to like Halo Wars
2 for those of us interested in it and
then the eventual Halo 6 which they've
said will be on PC right from the launch
I believe uh so that'll be a first for
them but anyway yeah tlor 5 Guardians
forge mode on PC and Windows 10 now uh
if you plan on playing it if you plan on
checking out Forge if you're a big fan
of forge on consoles and want to try it
on PC uh leave your thoughts in the
comments
below Rob you've been having a tough
time with a certain game the last few
days haven't you oh yeah yeah Halo five
no just kidding uh r r yeah r r the last
game from two tribes developer about a
year or two ago tokori one two and they
essentially just announced their early
retirement from game development they
said essentially the they called
themselves dinosaurs in the blog and
they said that there's just too many
things to keep up with they've been
developing games since 2000 and they
can't really keep up with twitch and
just like this explosion of IND games
that like there's the Market's flooded
or this is what they were paraphrasing
well I guess I'm I'm like making this
gesture I talked to them back during GDC
and they actually wanted to make it very
this isn't like a we can't keep up kind
of thing like that's not the basis of it
what's really driving their their new
direction to back out is they told me
that they've kind of accomplished what
they set out to do like they've figured
out okay these are the games we want to
make we figured out how to make them and
RVE is sort of like their game the thing
they've been working towards this whole
time both like develop the skills and
development and business and and all of
that so yeah I think it's partially like
that but I think it's got more to do
with like those aren't the challenges
they set out to accomplish developing
cool games is what they set out to
accomplish and they feel like they've
done it at this point cool well that's I
guess that's admirable I think a lot of
developers probably I'm not developer
but you hear like horror stories about
Crunch and development and like how a
lot of people just like get in that
cycle and don't know how to get out of
that hamster wheel I guess so that's
good on them for doing that uh now R is
out it's out today out today uh you've
been playing it Rob you said have pretty
tough I mean I I go back and forth with
with how I feel about the difficulty
like on one hand I think it's a hard ass
game and the other the game actually
makes me feel this way uh I'll get into
that but I feel like I'm a loser and I
suck at video
games because just to explain that
further is this game is crazy I I'm not
I'm not um this is not my type of style
of game necessarily kind like that
Contra fast moving always be shooting so
there are moments where like I had to
learn okay I can't just you can't stay
still you got to always move um but this
game will beat you up like a Dark Souls
game like you just you will enter a room
and it's just like oh lava's coming out
what are you going to do you got half a
second to figure it out you're
constantly dying and every time you die
there's a new message that pops up and
it says stuff like wrecked with the K or
like you suck literally like you suck it
makes it personal it makes I felt like I
had a roller coaster of a Time first I
was like this is way too hard then when
it was those messages actually I be I
became a fan of because tough love right
yeah like there it's just it's beating
you down and the only thing you can do
is climb out of it or you quit the game
and you walk away like a coward so there
like my best moments or favorite moments
in this game were when I'm talking like
12 deaths 20 deaths cannot get past this
one part there was even a message and I
don't know if this is because the build
we had was a little interesting I'm
pretty sure this is this was in the game
but a menu came up and it's like oh like
you want it to turn down the difficulty
to like fuzzy wuzzy mode or something
like that and it wouldn't let me click
it so I had to click keep click hard and
keep going uh and then if I just baiting
you to just bit so it's it's it's kind
of fun in that respect so yeah again
like eventually I'm I'm I was
legitimately mad and kicked ass on that
fume uh and was able to get out of those
situations many of times and I it just
felt like a real intentional part of the
game um yeah it's fun it's fun to move
around uh now having played a few hours
last night I
it wasn't it wasn't dying so constantly
that that got me um burn out but it was
more or less kind of like what was
happening in the later half of the game
we like you know it's like Mission six
or five and it's like oh they're
throwing you into the same map but now
it's zero g okay yeah just artificially
inflating it yeah and and just to also
clarify for people who don't know about
the game there's like three kind of more
or less what's nice is they keep turning
off and on mechanics of the game but
generally it's like you have your
asteroides Sid scrolling um type of game
and then it's like a walk around kind of
you know go through uh cordor and stuff
and then it's like an underwater zero g
type stuff but anyways they so they
throw those in back and forth but it's
like man when I'm repeating the same map
or level design but now it's in Zerg I'm
not getting much out of that uh that
plus the the character of the game you
know Peter we saw this actually at PAX
East a few years ago and this did not
have this narrative right character I
mean the yeah it was like a you know a
compact demo they had but yeah I mean
what you describe to me as something
that's kind of new to me yeah it's just
this character who I couldn't remember
his name so I tried looking up and
protagonist he's actually the character
inside your uh bot you're like thing
that you control okay and his name is
like literally it's like snake pilot
like he doesn't even have like an actual
name anyways he's like a Stallone guy
that's always like talking and
everything basically given this the
story beats however he's for me I just
not a big fan of it when a game is like
making fun of like the video game
industry and it's like oh man there's
one time I was like oh man these
firstperson shooter guys don't have this
perspective like this is way cooler or
wait what's wrong with that it's just or
uh oh look it's like an Asteroids game
it's like this game is cool and Visually
uh appealing to me I i' rather have no
story and just kind of immerse myself in
there's also like a a side antagonist
robot that's kind of lurring you around
it' be just to have that he could just
lure you around that's fine that's all I
need I want to feel like a little like I
want to have questions but this guy is
just he's just constantly talking and
it's something I wish I could just
literally turn off and that was just
kind of overwhelming and and just
getting me annoyed with the game toward
the end or I didn't beat it but like
towards my last play to go back to
gameplay for a second does the
difficulty ramp up or are you pretty
much just thrown into the fire right
away you're you're throwing in the fire
pretty quick uh you start off yeah again
um I should mention that so you have
your main gun right here which is always
on that's like your sole means of like
survival and as the game progress you
get unlocks you get armor upgrades uh
via bolts that are uh gathered from
enemies and so you get um different
types of weapons shotgun missiles and
stuff like that um you get to hack
robots as well that like help you yeah
yeah you get to hack uh like Health
robots or even turret robots to like Aid
you um I'm sorry what was your question
again I I was curious if the difficulty
you said the difficulty like throws you
into the fire right away I'm asking
because played at prep uh PA Prime last
year MH and I think it was an earlier
Mission but I was telling Pete I looked
up a gameplay video cuz I didn't think I
had played R yet I was like oh my God I
have played this game and it was at P it
was uh I think Pax did uh might have
been like the Xbox uh
Indie uh program forget the name of it's
escaping me right now but uh it was ID
at Xbox thank you uh myself but um it
was it didn't seem that hard I was
playing an earlier Mission and I think
it was just a lot slower Pace than what
I've seen here and you were describing
to me as like a contra bullet hell
platformer so I'm sure they were going
for difficulty the whole time maybe I
just didn't play enough of it to get
that sense because looking at these
gameplay vide it clearly looks very
frantic and difficult it is so let me
paint you a picture there are some
moments in this game where they cleverly
introduce elements that affect your
Mobility so the mobility factor is huge
because you get these this an onslaught
of drones who are just trying to run you
out of the world uh they're just
waves constant waves and you have to
keep avoiding and keep shooting as you
are trying to avoid them but then a
monster will or a monster a robot will
show up and he'll just be dropping
crates randomly now there are stacks and
crates that have to jump over that keep
cap that keep basically changing the the
level formation that like I have a
harder time jumping over these crates
and then more and more robots come so it
like it definitely builds and builds in
that particular level with the um Lava
yeah like those uh running lava balls
keep happening you know toward the end
of like his health is the boss's health
is like toward the end like those things
will just keep coming faster and faster
so yes it like I don't know what you
played but like each moment especially
boss fights definitely pick up and
that's where I typically die is right in
the end of that stretch um I feel like
this very much like a dark souls thing
too right like you know the guy will
just start throwing you he'll mutate or
waiting for Dark Souls esque yeah oh it
I mean I I actually never played I was
going to say it I never played really
any Dark Souls but like hearing you guys
talk about it and like the feelings and
seeing it you know on streams and stuff
it reminded me of that and the
frustration factor and you will die in
this game a lot all right interesting
I'm always down for a difficult game
kind of been not having my fill of those
lately except for maybe record that got
kind of difficult when I was playing it
we'll talk about that soon but uh anyway
yeah that's R it's out now on PS4 and PC
and uh yeah so that's the last game from
two tribes developers that's their swans
song anyway rocket League got pretty
crazy recently dude man I'm I'm so
bummed I haven't played it yet because
it took like two minutes after we
started playing before our Jaws were
just on the desk like what the hell have
they done in a good way yeah I think I
haven't gotten to play it yet I was on
the East Coast all last week when it
came out and uh kind of it's
extreme man they they know their game
they know what they're doing psionic is
they just listen I feel like and so many
times so just touching back on their
last one right was Hoops which was cool
fun idea changes the game because you
know you're doing aerial and all this
stuff Neo Tokyo to be fair that's a that
would be another example of what I'm
getting at is okay the essence of Rocket
League that I think where people kind of
like eventually step away from these new
updates is that you can't change the
core game you can't change the maps
specifically because that is part of the
core game is riding up walls and knowing
where to be for Aerials and stuff like
that you know changing the ball physics
you can't do that this game keeps all
that intact but just adds like a power
up ability right you can teleport to
where another player is you can use a
plunger to grab the ball you can use a
harpoon to bring yourself towards the
ball you can attach spikes to your car
so you can stick to the ball you can
create a tornado effect that throws cars
uh in your way like off their path you
can shoot another opponent oh right
which which basically it's like cutting
the brakes and throwing it into NOS so
you see these guys it's like you shoot
them and like they're spinning out of
control um it's real fun and I I played
that the most over the weekend I could
not stop playing that mode um it's
really fun and I think in a very good
way it like
preserves rocket League like you know
because you start off the game it's you
know these modes or these abilities come
in 10 second just keep watching you
punch the ball into the goal that's so
that's the hay maker and that and the
spikes are like the ones you want to
hold on to and and wait for the moments
CU ask you this do they if you don't use
it do you lose
it no you you don't lose it but you lose
the opportunity to get another ability
sure so certain ones you want to get rid
of you can still hold on to it oh
exactly so the Haymaker and the spikes
you want to hold on to that because
that's your main offensive push freeze
it in the middle of the air as well um
re in the twitch chat is just asking if
there's a power up to just puncture the
ball and end the
game it's like uh what The Sandlot scene
he's like idiot now we can't play no
more anyway um yeah I it's a really fun
game and I think uh uh yeah I mean I'm
super into it and it you know eventually
yeah what I was going to say is you know
these things come in 10-second cooldown
so you're still playing rocket league in
moments right the game or a round or a
goal will happen it's rocket league for
10 seconds and every 10 seconds
thereafter like you're still using your
your skills for the game and nothing's
changed other than now you're you're
learning and trying new things with like
all right now I got to like use spikes
in a in a manner where I'm going to
Aerial up and attach to in midair and
just like have hands on my car and just
run this thing the go drive it up the
wall and hold on to it and see if anyone
can catch you what you talk about in
terms of that flow is like super
apparent because like yeah for that
moment where like no one's using a power
up and you're going to score a goal and
you're like all right easy I got this
it's like everyone activates their
powers at once it seems like and then
suddenly the ball is pulled to the other
end of the map then it's frozen in
midair and then just like all those
other powers come into play it's it's
super interesting um and I think you
know like a lot of people were worried
that doing stuff like this would impact
the core gameplay but like you said they
found a really good
balance yeah I I I think so and you know
those rocket lab Maps where they changed
the map and everything I think you know
I'm sure there are people who get a kick
out of that stuff but as far as like
General consensus I feel like like
around the office and like even on yeah
it's cool at first nice to try something
different but you just want to preserve
that that feeling we all had for like
the first you know initial months of
that game where it was like I just want
to get good at this and you know you're
you're still everyone's still striving
to get better at that core game right um
so this is I think I think this is
actually like the perfect way to like
let off some steam if you're having if
you're having a bunch of uh you just had
a sixa with your spikes I know well
that's what rocket League was always
appealing because for as unpredictable
as it could be its mechanics were
predictable so you get really good and
master this game whereas this seems like
it's doing the opposite it's just
throwing these wrenches into the cogs
and I'm wondering it didn't initially
sound appealing to me but like watching
gameplay obvious it looks really fun but
I'm wondering if it's kind of the the
systems are still in place for it to be
something you can Master rather than
have these cool uh powerups actually
just disrupting the entire formula I
think it goes back and forth I think
because these powerups happen randomly
that if you know you are skilled and
you're learning you're doing whatever
you are and you've mastered the spikes
someone can still pull you out of it and
that's both uh skill of that player and
it's also just luck and it's just the
luck of the situation of the game so as
long as you can Embrace that and just be
okay with letting you know someone just
School you with one of these spikes or
hay maker then you're having a good time
and again I think it's like a nice
balance with the actual game because
let's get real like you know you do 2
V2s online competitive and you're going
to have what five streaks of just losing
like I don't know I I think it's a nice
change up it's it's like all right it's
need to like rethink my life yeah it's
an excellent option yeah so another
thing with the update is this the you
said you're finding on Reddit like uhuh
this trading system which is becoming
almost like a cedy underbelly almost of
the rocket League Community which
obviously I'm not speaking ill of Rocket
league but you were saying you were
looking through Reddit and kind of
digging through like neoa forums about
how people are kind of selling these
crazy crates for like 90 real world
dollars now they're pushing Keys bro
yeah it's Keys man that's the well 90
real world dollars translates into keys
right no let me preface all this so
they've int they've introduced they've
introduced crates and keys crates are
obtainable uh I would say roughly around
you know maybe a dozen matches or so you
can get a random crate drop different
system compared to the items that are
introduced into the game um that's
completely separate so you get a random
crate drop great what's inside it about
a dozen exclusive uh there are two
different types you get Champions one
and Champion 2 each has like a bunch of
uh wide range of different Rarity items
including like two import cars that are
like unique you know Dominus variants
and stuff like that they're all of it
looks so good it's all like really
exclusive uh cool items however in order
to open that crate you need to buy keys
and there is no other way you can get
keys other than trading with other
people but you're more inclined to open
these things up at least one or two I
don't know keys are about a $150 each or
20 for 20 um so you open it up and it's
a random luck of the draw whatever is in
that crate you can potentially get so
you I lucked out on my second one I
opened I opened four and I'm not going
to open any more ever again uh who knows
but anyways I opened one and I got that
um Tumi
rxt rare model and it's dope it's I saw
that you tweeted the other night right
God I yeah this is right screamed dude
it's kind like a clear Hood you can see
the engine sounds awesome what oh man
that so this is where I'm already
getting like conflicted and frustrated
is because I really want this
however there are things you can do in
this game to avoid purchasing keys this
is where it gets this is where it's like
oh my god what happened to Rocket
League um it's become like the auction
house from Diablo I first thing you can
do if you don't like the system at all
is you can turn it off entirely so you
cannot see it visually in the game which
is nice so you don't see the buy Keys
option you know we're talking about Halo
earlier like I don't want to see that
it's not just shoved down your throat
right which is great uh two I can um
basically never open a crate get five
crates
either turn turn them uh trade them into
the game and get a random um piece of
loot back or item back that's of higher
Rarity so that could be one of these new
like animated skins that are really cool
looking or here's the real kicker is or
I could hit the web and go to of course
subreddit rocket League exchange and
already you see it and there's this is
auctions so people who have unlocked a
crate and have gone like the ominous GT
and it's a legit car people want that a
lot he goes I'll start first this one
guy first he links to like an auction
song in his description on Reddit and
he's like I'll start the bid at 30 keys
and then you see scroll down 60 90 some
guy is paying 90 Keys which is give or
take
$80 so that's the currency now it's
rocket League keys and so you can do
player Trader item uh trading you can do
keys switch is the currency or yeah you
know it's like you see other people or
other way you can do it is you see
people go like I have these rims which
is actually the one I was thinking of
he's like I got these rims and that's
what he sold rims for
$80 or it could be I'm looking for this
you see like want this looking for this
what was the base game $15 or
20 oh 20 20 yeah sure point being you're
you're paying like quadruple for rims
than you paid for the actual game that
they're set in that's nuts there are
people enthusiasts that like rocket
League including us but I don't think I
would do that I definitely wouldn't buy
rims for that although your car is
pretty sick I'll give you like I'll buy
you lunch tomorrow for that c but I'm
done but I'm done I like so give it to
me this is I mean I felt that I felt
that addiction I mean it was like I got
to open another one I did item next
onee yeah practically and next one is
the same and I was like I'm done and I S
I turned it off but I'm pretty sure the
point being it's like maybe in a month
or so I could uh
uncheck that option and see how many
crates I have which I could flip I don't
know yeah because it reminds me of
OverWatch except OverWatch is like you
see how much you're getting a pretty
standard experience amount each match
like obviously do better you'll get a
little more but um depending on what
medals you get but then you open the
crates with the currency whereas rocket
League sounds more like it's very very
rare to get a crate unless like you said
you're kind of falling through the ranks
on purpose to rise through them and get
those streaks in the lower ranks which
psionic said they're going to start
Banning people who are manipulating the
system right that's the really weird
thing is p people
intentionally quitting games in order to
get yeah I mean you said in order to get
that Nerf because I guess that's kind of
a I mean I guess it's not confirmed but
it's a mechanic of that of that CR drop
is how many wins you have in a row so
yeah it's interesting but I don't know
I'm still a huge fan of the game I think
it's a weird move but I also think
opting out of that is like no harm no
foul right like the game is still fun
it's just Cosmetics yeah um I'm still
having a blast with it I know yeah you
guys are too yeah I'm hoping to get in
this afternoon I still have not played
it but anyway so yeah that's uh Rumble
mode in rocket League's newest update
along with the trading system and
whatnot which is kind of becoming a
little shady in a little areas but
anyway let me know what the craziest
thing you've done in rocket League's new
update in the comments below because I
have not seen half the stuff I saw like
Spike saves and haym maker shots but
anyway going to talk recor all right
finally it's as the reviewer segment I
guess but Tamor Hussein in the UK is
obviously not here it's pretty late
their time maybe he's watching yeah so
I'm going to kind of ask you guys about
it Pete you and I have played the game I
played it at preview events probably
like three total hours maybe at this
point um foll yeah you've been following
the game for a while uh I guess
everybody has cuz you know it's got the
inun name attached to it but uh so what
what do you think of the game from what
you've seen been following for a while
and I think it was around E3 when I
started to hear things about it that got
me really interested um yes I like kg
and aun's uh older work uh but Armature
Studios uh you know they're involved in
this and those are made from a lot of EX
people who made Metroid Prime at retro
uh so then I started to hear the game is
sort of like feels like a like a 3 or
128bit game like you know PlayStation 2
era kind of action game and that sounds
appealing because things have become
kind of bloated you know in a sense so
to revisit that old style of gameplay
sounded really fun uh toor's review
basically described a game that is what
I was looking for until the very end
where he ended up getting uh to a point
like every other reviewer where You'
essentially finish the campaign by going
through you know Quest by Quest and then
it's like we need you to backtrack and
collect items that are hard to find you
do that and then it's like I need you to
do it again but get more this time and
that process repeats itself uh that
sounds kind of crappy so anyway I spent
about half hour with the game playing it
myself uh before coming on here which
isn't enough to get a really great
impression but mechanically like moment
to moment it feels pretty good but I did
encounter two bugs that made me have to
restart the game within 30 minutes one
of them within 5 minutes the one you
showed me was essentially the world
itself had gone white and or you're on
like a cliff on the edge of a white
Abyss I finished the first boss fight
and I walk out and I see this hill and
then beyond that is just white and I
thought oh this is going to teach me to
air Dash to some random thing that I
can't quite see and I was like no wait
there are things just walking in midair
and I was like oh yeah I there's nothing
in front of me the game has not rendered
the world around me but before that
there's a a mission where you're trying
to dash through a door uh you stand on a
pressure sensitive button you have to
dash fast enough get through the door
before it closes once you step off I
apparently was like just at the right
time for the door to catch me and lock
me in the Dr in the geometry above the
door and I couldn't get out so yeah know
I had an auto save which was fine I had
to exit but this is a game that also has
like really long loading screens and you
kind of take all this into account you
take the padding into account as well
and you've got a game that do that's
really rough around the edges it seems
based on my experience and based what a
lot of people are reporting including
toore yeah said there were about four
big bugs he encountered on Xbox One
during his playthrough sure yeah um you
again it's a budget price game it's only
$40 uh which probably means something to
you know a lot of people who kind of
like weigh how much they want to spend
and it sounds like you'll get about you
know 8 to 10 hours of like a decent game
but but one that clearly maybe could
have benefited from a little bit more
time and attention towards the end game
which uh kind of just puts your back
against a wall it makes you complete
chores it felt repetitive to me from the
few uh hours I played I obviously like a
big part you upgrade uh her Jewel's
rifle juel being the protagonist uh but
then eventually you'll find enemies that
are like kind of different colored like
red yellow or blue and you just press a
direction on the d-pad to switch to that
color of ammunition because that happens
to be the weakness of that colored enemy
and I feel like that was a very uh lazy
attempt to upset the gameplay but then
you obviously like the driving force
being you're customizing your different
cores right the I think the cores being
those actual spheres that give it the
personality but then you can put
different frames on it so there's like
the dog that stuns people there's the uh
the bigger gorilla I think that his name
is Duncan Duncan that uh you can put
like hammers on his arms and whatnot and
make him he's like the brute and then
there's the spider one that uh like kind
of zip lines you around so that was the
like driving aspect for me is kind of
customizing them because there is like a
loot Fest kind of aspect too um there's
different color loot that you actually
pick up to customize them with um I'm
not sure if that plays into upgrading
the rifle but I think the main thing is
like obviously like we interviewed
recently and at a certain point where
like is the your Mega Mega Man Legacy
kind of actually negatively impacting
your future projects because everybody's
expecting them to be similar because a
lot of people said this is like a 3D
Mega Man combined with Metroid Prime
which the Metroid Prime aspect was more
appealing to me but it doesn't sound
like that really came through because
like you said the uh item gating later
on is like these specific Quest items
you need to go back and just like
tediously search for rather than like
Metroid Prime which actually like you
got a new item that affected how you
play and how you fight your enemies but
then you just happened to come into a
part of the world that you've been
before and you're like oh now I can do
this this sounds more tedious and I
don't know that that's appealing to me
at all I don't want to get to the late
game and then realize I have to go back
and find one more of these cores and God
knows where it is this might be one of
those games where you don't need to beat
it like you can feel good about just
getting to a certain point and being
like yeah that's fine I mean after half
hour I kind of want to keep playing um I
I like the way movement feels I like the
way shooting feels it's it's aw auto aim
but there's something to be said for
that because it opens you up to Greater
mobility and enemies can force you to
move around a lot more but you can keep
you know uh the action going while
that's all happening so I I find that
kind of encouraging
um and I do see that I do see the kind
of Mega Man combat in the sense that
you're jumping and dodging in midair and
then you're dodging and kind of coming
back around to shoot from the other side
uh and that did seem like an engaging
gameplay loop I don't know how much it
would have how long it would have lasted
for me after the you know like hourong
preview I played yeah I mean I think at
this point we he's not helping his case
with a game like money number n but it'd
probably be healthy if people could look
past Mega Man when looking at something
kg andoni doeses I think because Mega
Man has influenced so many things that
we now take for granted in games that
it's really easy to just look at that
and say oh yeah there's the connection
definitely um but I don't think it hurts
or or benefits the game in this case
necessarily I think this game kind of
stands on its own um and how's like the
narrative for story I'm really
interested in in in what what are these
balls of energy that are Mac and all
these characters is there like an
explanation some like a dust the what
they call the dust devil storm or
something like that took out the world
or something so from what I understand
yeah it's pretty much um kind of like an
Interstellar thing where Jewel has come
to the planet to try to find new uh
colonizable Planets For Humanity from
what I understand and she kind of comes
at this dust planet and starts to
discover things that she didn't expect
to be here I don't know how the core is
playing to I just think that they're
like the source of energy on this
particular planet but I didn't play
enough to really get into the narrative
I know tomorrow was saying it's nothing
spectacular but it drives the action
forward I guess as far as like you know
just making it a vehicle for the combat
that's good um I I don't know that I
find the world looks kind of like that
Borderlands one like I get sick of the
desert after a while sure um it doesn't
look vibrant uh not that every game
needs to be and like like I said this
makes sense this dust plan like this
decrepit kind of uh Barren place but I
don't know it looks like a maybe over
eight hours it would get annoying but I
don't know doesn't seem particularly
interesting to me damn yeah well I don't
know from what I played in the game it
does it kind of got tough later in the
game we played late game missions and we
were the uh we being the people that I
was playing with at at Gamescom we were
playing and a lot of us died and they
the developers are saying like a lot of
times they'll just say oh you're the
only one to beat it to make you feel
better maybe you'll write a better
preview but I was seeing people die left
and right around me the monitors were
right next to me and it got tough I mean
you're balancing shooting these
different guys who it kind of became
like a you know shooting at like sponge
sponge bosses or whatever later on and
it did feel like it could like I said
wear thin after a while I think Tamor
said it does a pretty good job of
introducing new wrinkles to actually
keep it somewhat interesting throughout
um but yeah I don't know I I don't have
any immediate draw to the game right now
um yeah so there Tamor Hussein who
reviewed it it's a six on Gamespot you
can read the full review uh in the
meantime that is on Xbox One and PC yes
and you get a it's cross byy so you buy
one get both cool so yeah play it on
Windows 10 or Xbox One all
right PS4
Pro Pete you're like our one of our
resident Tech experts and you can Expert
Tech spurts wow Tech te e c spurt like
you're spurting Tech yes uh I was at the
PlayStation event in New York last week
yeah it was relatively light compared to
what I thought I mean I'm surprised they
showed both I mean we definitely
expected the slim because we knew like
for those leaks that Sony you know still
didn't confirm it after those leaks a
few weeks ago but uh yeah they showed
off the pro as well with like HDR
compatibility uh obviously like a 4K if
you have a 4K TV uh I don't know it's
the club sandwich of video game consoles
yeah three layers that's what I was
going to say yeah uh PS4 Pro it's uh
interesting times we are in you know
we've seen a lot of consoles kind of get
these like Hardware revisions some with
like the most modest upgrades that maybe
a developer would notice but you
wouldn't
uh Pro is sort of and you can maybe
point to Xbox One S but PS4 Pro is
really the first step in terms of um you
know these like semi console Generations
aren't going to exist anymore it seems
like these are just like you know uh
midterm updates uh to a system and it's
coming with things like HDR and 4K and
there's a lot of stipulations there in
terms of how those things will apply I
mean the nice thing is that the HDR
feature will apply to all PlayStation 4s
unlike Xbox one which is currently only
doing it on the S but 4K is pretty much
the focus of the pro uh we can also
assume VR will be a focus um and it's
going to be interesting I think for
developers as well as the audience to
deal with this uh division of the market
you were just telling me the other day
we were talking about Battlefield one uh
having you know they had that bundle
announced on Monday that was like you
know HDR support whatever we I was like
digging deeper because I don't know too
much about the p uh PS Pro but that also
depends on the developer releasing the
HDR 4K for for PlayStation Pro
specifically right they have to allow
that to happen they yeah so 4K is not a
guarantee um it sounds like now we're
going to see some games that are native
4K they're going to be very modest games
in terms of technical demands other
games will render at a lower resolution
be scaled up to Output at 4K so it'll
still fill your 4K TV at that resolution
but it's not rendered natively there
um HDR seems to be a thing like 4K that
is going to be optional for developers
and if they if they want to have it work
they have to enable it in terms of like
sure you might get hdr on the
PlayStation 4 Pro even though standard
PS4 supports HDR I don't think that
means you're automatically going to get
it for any game that supports it on
Playstation Pro this confusion is just
is already confusing as hell yeah and
you're wondering if this is just
becoming the reality of obviously like
console Generations now reacting like
how long they take like PC audiences
they've always been used to this stuff
like upgrading Tech but it's still it's
weird because I think being consoles
people assume it's just going to be this
set Evolution that takes place yes and
you know I think with PC like you said
people are used to the idea that the
quality of a game is going to be in flux
relative to their Hardware console
Gamers have always just expected a
certain standard um and I think a lot of
that will persist but it's going to
become difficult when people are just
choosing what console to buy it's not
going to be does does is my console
strong enough for this game right like
once they have a PS4 Pro or a slim I
think people are going to understand
like okay I can really only focus on
games that have this Tech um but making
that choice that's going to be hard for
a lot of people yeah but luckily for
Sony once people make that decision
they're pretty much in good shape and I
think you're going to see a lot of
people picking up the pro as opposed to
the slim sure uh what do you think of
the price points now that you're
speaking about slim and pro so the slim
starts at 300 right and then Pro is four
right uh so we don't know how much
Scorpio is going to cost it sounds like
Microsoft is you know based on their
their presentation E3 like really
doubling down on this thing and trying
to hit a home run that might be a more
expensive system um but one of the
things driving down the cost of the pro
is that it doesn't have a UHD Blu-ray
Drive in it which means you cannot watch
4K content off of a disc you have to
stream it that is something that is
built into the Xbox One S yeah that
seems like a weirdo mission for the pro
do you why that might have been the case
um I think it's a it's an easy move for
Sony to keep cost down
because um let's be honest I think 4K
for a lot of people it's going to be
hard to discern that difference unless
something like you know you walk into a
store and you see these like really
intricate Nature Documentaries on 4K and
like yeah a flower under a macro lens is
going to look amazing but but like a
Hollywood Blockbuster like you're going
to you know in the explosion and the
fire you're going to miss all that stuff
as it's moving by really fast so I think
cutting cost there allowing people to
stream 4K from Services they already
subscribe to is not going to necessarily
hamper their 4K entertainment experience
they'll have access to it um for
Microsoft I think it's a boon for the
Xbox 1s that helps them sell that system
a little bit better it is the cheapest
UHD player out there on the other hand
it is strange it's not on the pro
because Sony basically owns the Blu-ray
format it is something that they
pioneered and that they have been a
champion of for so long so it's a little
strange um and that starts at $400 am I
correct for the the pro I think that has
an excellent price
um it's going to it's going to be really
telling uh how it'll impact PlayStation
VR and how many games can really support
4K for people to understand that
argument and really go for it
um and if you don't have a 4K TV I don't
even have like, you're probably going to
drop people people like to Future proof
how many of us bought Xbox 360s before
we had an HDTV right you know definitely
and that's the thing with it was
definitely it was I definitely did buy
one before I had refurbished 360 I I
still have my launch day 360 that never
got it got a red ring but I wrapped the
towel around it and I still have it I'm
not kidding it's still on the towel yeah
it's in a tow I haven't checked if it
works but it's still in my room in a
towel no but um I got to see a few games
up close cuz HDR obviously like you were
saying it's definitely more noticeable
than 4K to me yes for yeah I think yeah
and HDR is the exciting thing for me CU
like obviously if you have like any kind
of like interest in photography HDR is a
big deal like Phone iPhones have it now
as of the six I believe but the thing
with the it was kind of weird because at
the presentation people around me were
all saying they showed a few games
during the presentation with the old
Graphics as opposed to the HDR and then
uh we went backstage and naughty dog had
both The Last of Us remastered and
Uncharted 4 obviously The Last of Us
remastered at its foundation as a PS3
game still looked really good with on
the PS4 Pro but then they had a button
that they had equipped like I think they
were pressing the touchpad for the
purposes of this uh presentation and
they're switching between the like
Nathan Drake was swimming underwater and
a coral reef at one point later in like
in a libertalia onch 4 but the original
footage looked worse like I was like I
just played this game in March or
whatever it was I don't remember looking
that bad and like I thought I was just
being crazy but and I don't want to I'm
not like accusing Sony or naughty dog or
anything but do it other people were
saying is that just looking this bad in
comparison to the PS4 Pro with HDR HDR
definitely looked really good but the
original footage looked like it had an
extra layer of fog over it it depends a
lot on the TV you're playing and the
settings that are applied to it maybe
those TVs weren't Cali appropriately
yeah I don't know maybe it just looks
that much inally different I mean yeah
or yeah you wonder like if there was any
doctoring to make the old footage look
worse in comparison that's weird but
here's the thing I don't think they
would do that because HDR is going to
work for existing PlayStation 4 owners
it doesn't influence their decision to
buy a PS4 Pro so there's actually no
incentive for Sony to do that right if
you've got a PS4 already it's going to
work and I think a lot of people at
those events have one probably are you
guys tempted to buy the pro now I mean
obviously the slim is good for people
who don't have a PS4 there's no reason
to buy a PS for slim purportedly if you
have it for already I want to know I
want to know more about the
manufacturing process that goes into
this CU my PS4 I like the way it looks
it's a little loud I want a quieter
system if the PS4 Pro can give me more
power and be quieter than the standard
PS4 yeah probably a couple years I'll
buy one yeah if if they're going to
adopt this like apple esque S release
why can't we have that whole system
right like why can't I exchange my PS4
well you can you can take it to GameStop
and get 20 bucks for it
that's just like that's what's the
killer for me you know and I'm sure for
everyone it's like like my buddy buddy
of mine just got a PS4 and I showed him
this and he's like
great I don't know it's just I think
I'll eventually get one I mean that's
you know this is like our job here you
you want to have the best equipment for
the job but I don't know that's such a
kill 400 bucks is a lot yeah I mean it
was actually I I think it's a fair price
point compared to what I thought it
would be but at this point yeah 400
doesn't seem like something I want to
drop on this but then another thing that
the presentation about the presentation
that stood out that if we had been
talking about is they never once during
the presentation said this is the most
powerful console like remember like the
Xbox One for the Scorpio presentation
they were like this is going to be the
most powerful console ever made at this
point right and like you were just
touching on this how like this in a lot
of ways can become a boon for the
Scorpio um and the S because of its
Blu-ray capabilities but I know it's
almost like Sony's pushing the this is
the most powerful console for the time
being in November whenever it launches
with PlayStation VR and everything yeah
but you think they would have pushed
that if that were true but I mean
obviously like the Scorpio is still the
one that I'm more curious about I think
Sony is doing their best to court
existing PlayStation owners to buy the
new version I think their market share
kind of speaks for itself in relation to
Microsoft where Microsoft really has to
account for the fact that they've had
the weaker of the two main consoles
since launch and that has been the
narrative around it
so maybe it's true that Sony's
Playstation 4 Pro will not be as
powerful as Scorpio who knows if they
know that or not but they also don't
need to really try to back up that claim
and if they were to make that claim now
before Scorpio's announced and we really
know what's in it and proved wrong that
would suck sure so I I can I can
understand why they wouldn't do that
yeah it's you know it's like we try to
like avoid absolutes like absolute
statements and previews and stuff like
that for a good reason right because
things change and we don't always know
everything and I think that's the place
where Sony is right now it's interesting
to look at you wonder how much of this
is just a reaction to Microsoft to
Scorpio obviously like rumors the Neo
came out like when Giant Bomb had been
reporting on the actual like information
about it um you wonder if they pushed
this up farther because of the Scorpio
and like obviously like NX news is
rumored to be coming out really soon now
and that's going to be what like quarter
2 next year March perly okay you wonder
how much of this is like reactionary as
opposed to something Sony had planned
all along I don't know how fast they can
pivot in that respect when it comes to
the actual economics behind the scenes
and like you said manufacturing which I
don't have much background in but I
don't know I'm wondering if this was
something they pushed forward a little
bit well the good thing about um for
Sony and Microsoft is they're working
with AMD to make parts that are
relatively simple for manufacturers of
those chips to adapt to uh in the past
you know the PlayStation 3 was Notorious
for being the most inefficient console
to create uh the chips that powered it
uh for various reasons um I think this
has more to do potentially with the
launch of PlayStation VR more than
anything that's that's sort of spurred
Sony's expedience in this regard to get
out there first I think they were just
ready to frankly
um and you know it's it's also worth
noting that maybe Microsoft is biting
their time so they can wait and see what
other people do before they actually
commit to what Scorpio is it might be
the inverse it might not be Sony being
reactionary it might be Microsoft just
being slow or you know patient's sure
yeah anyway um the slim is definitely
obviously like I said for like people
who might not be in the game yet as far
as this console generation goes but the
pro is the one that like we're looking
for especially with like you consider
Pro coming out plus buying psvr which is
how much $400 so 400 plus 400 plus if
you haven't upgraded to a 4K TV yet that
could be like 1,800 bucks if you want to
completely upgrade all at once isuse it
that much I thought 4K TVs were fairly I
was thinking they around, I could off
$500 well you want to get one that's a
decent size CU you're not going to
notice the difference in resolution if
you have something that's like 32 in I
don't even know if you can buy it I'm
sure you can but you really want to be
like 50 inches and
above okay
yeah and so beyond that there are a lot
of different things that come uh like
with HDR like you need to get a TV that
has 4K and the proper HDR support I've
seen people who have been picking up
Xbox One s's thinking their TV is up to
Snuff they plug it in and the console is
like yeah you're missing this stuff you
can get a little bit of a benefit so
it's like if you want to get the TV that
has everything you need you're not going
to be buying that cheap knockoff made in
China not knockoff you're not going to
be buying you know that uh Eon economic
4K TV you're going to be buying one
that's a little bit more robust or like
the first generations of 4K right like
they've improved over the years so those
are like the leftovers I guess right
sure so what what's the price range for
like a 4 4K TV I was thinking like a
nice like a decent one was like a
thousand I could be overshooting that I
was looking uh the other day during this
announcement just Loosely not really
like based on these hard specs I was
just referring to and I kept seeing 60
in between $800 and $1,000 okay from
people like Samsung like manufacturers
that's like okay I will probably look to
you um I me you can get a 4K TV cheapap
but will it support everything else I
don't know isth at that point is it
worth it at that point sure so anyway
yeah this the PS4 slim is releasing
September 15th 2016 and that's going to
be $300 whereas PS4 Pro is November 10th
2016 for $400 so let us know what you
think do you have a PS4 already and
you're planning on getting a slim
probably not are you planning on getting
a pro November 10th let us know in the
comments below Rob unfortunately you've
been on the whole show but I have to
kick you off wait before you go what are
you planning what are you working on
what are you playing oh gez I've been
doing news all week so that's most my uh
my time but um gez man uh put on the
spot put on the spot I don't know I'm
trying to work on something I think I
want to dive into Forge to be honest
cool I think people have um already been
like going nuts and that stuff so uh
maybe I'll I think I maybe do like a
compilation of like hottest cool maps
who knows Rob made make a few Star Wars
Maps sure with prefabs awesome well
thanks for coming on Rob thanks for
having me cool going to talk Destiny
we're goingon to bring Eric ton our
resident Destiny expert oh man talk
about that in a second I don't know what
else are you playing uh I'm still
playing Dragon Quest 7 uh oh yeah I put
up the review in progress today after
playing for 50 hours and no one really
cares uh Dragon Quest is a Series has
never really been popular in America but
um I've waited to play this game for a
very long time it is very long it is
very classic in some good ways and not
so good ways so I will continue to play
that uh until I can finish my full
review cool but enough from me Eric Tay
what's up what's up this seat is warm
thanks forart it's a lot it's hot Rob
for
you no I'm just kidding anyway yeah you
were recently up at Bungie in Redmond or
bellev bellw Washington playing a little
bit if not all of Rise of iron which
regardless of what you did play we can
only talk about a little bit today
because there's embargo yesterday
there's embargo today and there's one on
the 20th which is tomorrow there's one
tomorrow there's one so there yeah
there's one Monday there's one tomorrow
or one today and one tomorrow every one
of them at 10 a.m. and it releases
September 20th next week but I did write
down what you can talk about good uh so
don't get me in trouble the title yeah
the release date so I mean just like
broader Strokes right now how does this
compare to like taken King because
obviously taken King like revamped
almost the foundation of how Destiny
worked in a lot of ways um but how rise
of iron what should we expect from this
as as far as like what it's doing for
Destiny before you know two purportedly
comes out next year or whenever sure um
well first of all since it is is priced
at $29.99 it's kind of like in between
what you would expect of like a taken
King and like their previous DLCs which
were $20 so it's a little bit meater
than just you know House of wolves or
the dark below but it's definitely um
same time less than taken King I don't I
can't speak too much into detail about
like you know how much it like changes
from Taken King but um I would say taken
King probably did more for the game like
overall then this will um but this has a
cool story that you know follows the
Lords of iron um so you get that kind of
background story about like you know
some of the guns you you uh farmed and
got from like the old iron banners like
who's Jer like you know that's a person
that you're going to learn about or
gilan if I'm saying his name right so
like there's some of that background
story so it's kind of like a building up
more of the world that already exists
and then kind of going into the new
social space too which I can't talk
about the social space but I can talk
about getting there um which is kind of
a cool setting because you've never
really seen the kind of like the snowy
mountain kind of stuff that you're
seeing right now um previously in
Destiny at least not that I can remember
um and it's kind of fun this is the
first mission uh it's kind of the first
uh 10 minutes that you go through give
or take depending on how you know slow
or fast you go but you kind of get to go
up that Gondola that's been in in the
trailers that's kind of cool and um
pretty much get to ascend a mountain to
to where these Lords of iron used to
kind of reside they're kind of their
headquarters you know where they were
based out of and they had I spoke to a
Bungie at Gamescom and they were saying
like if you can't tell already rise iron
is very influenced by like Game of
Thrones it's almost like a fantasy SciFi
setting now which like a lot of things
were influenced by Game of Thrones but
no like the first image they showed off
was uh who's the who's the main like
Lord of iron now Sal Saladin they showed
him with his hammer with his back to
like this big breach in a wall and the
two wolves and motion capture dog they
use for the wolves in this is the same
one they use for Jon Snow's direwolf
yeah he's like the Troy Baker dog
of video games um but yeah so you did
you got to play King of the mountain the
first mission is that the one where
you're ascending the up the mountain and
then you're going to by completing like
by fighting your way up that mountain
you'll essentially uh open access to
that social space unfortunately I can't
talk too much about it but it's just a
dance hall people just doing their
emotes there might be some of those new
ones you never know embargos are
screwing this whole thing up uh but then
there's also remastered strikes right
Devil's Lair and wretched eye yeah so um
SAA is this kind of like new thing that
you know they were trying to kind of
keep away because it was like really
powerful but the Fallen have essentially
gotten their hands on it and it's a
nanobot plague as Bungie was telling me
yeah so so they're using that to kind of
enhance like they haven't totally
figured it out yet but like they've used
it to like enhance themselves so that's
kind of where you start fighting
different enemies now because they're
kind of enhanced with the SAA so you'll
see you know drgs do some stuff that's a
little bit different where I think you
know if you kill them sometimes you know
they'll have like this exploding orb
that'll chase you and if you don't shoot
that orb you know you and your teammates
are going to get hurt so that's like one
Dynamic I think the vandals throw down
like those like mines that slow you and
so there's like a little bit of a
different Dynamic of gameplay in terms
of like the fall on you're dealing with
they're not exactly the same as you
fought them before um and the strikes
are kind of the same um but there's like
twists I guess so that's why you can
call them remastered strikes I guess
because you're kind of fighting the same
bosses Sand's like that um new one with
the ogre and the kind of like the archon
but like the seix one you pretty much go
through it the same way you got to fight
through the first part which is like in
a warehouse area which is like almost
the same just kind of different enemy
types A little bit it reminds me of like
the taken enemies they were kind of it
was like the three factions just like
redone a little bit with taking
abilities and whatnot like the scream
throw and that with that that one that
was super annoying though the captain
thing that would blind you yeah um so
it's kind of more like that I mean the
twists are interesting but like I would
say it's not that different you know
like sure you know sepic has like a
shield now around him that's based off
of a certain element type so there's
going to be a captain that's holding
like a cannon that you have to kill and
then you can't damage sepic until you
shoot him with the uh you know the type
of element that you need to get the
shield off and then you you resume DPS
at that point the first time I was like
oh that's pretty cool but then you know
you do it a couple more times and you're
like oh okay yeah it's just a little
trick and that's fine I guess what about
uh PVP mode I played a little bit at
Gamescom which is essentially what was
it's kill confirmed kirm it's called
Supremacy but it's essentially kill
confirmed so every time you kill um you
know an opposing Guardian they're going
to drop a Crest is what they're called
and I guess the uh unique twist is that
you can kind of see the emblem of the
class you killed I guess I never really
paid attention to it it was just more
like oh there's a like an engram looking
thing I better pick that up or you can
deny it Etc sure uh it was it's fun I
mean some of the maps almost seemed in a
way designed for that kind of mode cuz
there's a lot more uh areas where
there's like close quarters and whatnot
so you're just really fighting over the
the crests and whatnot so it's kind of
faster paced I would say I don't know if
it was Sky I think it was Skyline cuz
there's like S Bar we talk about Skyline
The Last Exit map I think it was Skyline
it was kind of like this exterior ring
around these Close Quarters inner
corridors and whatnot and that's where
that's where it got pretty hectic when
you were rounding a corner to get a dog
tag or whatever dog tag you Cod man you
love that c kill confirmed but
then yeah that that like makes you go
into there where like there's probably
three people with shotguns waiting for
you to come grab it it's kind of that
old thing with Call of Duty same thing
it's like do people bait the the crests
and have you like want to go pick it up
and just wait for you to kill you or are
people just going to chase after it it's
kind of that Dynamic that's not in
Destiny yet but I think if you played a
Call of Duty you're familiar with that
kind of type it's fun it's it's fast I
mean I think the new Iron Banner is
going to be uh Supremacy so that's
that's cool they've said that already it
it definitely feels like more of a DLC
in this sense than like a traditional
expansion whereas taken King felt like a
big expansion to me well it was this
still at least still has a raid too
which Come Out 3 days after I didn't get
to see the raid so I'm still interested
it comes out Friday to give people
enough time to kind of get up to speed
to to do it awesome yeah cool well that
is Destiny rise of iron the new
expansion coming out it'll be September
20th for PS4 Xbox One for $30 yep at 2
a.m. Pacific cool so that will be out in
uh next week yep you're reviewing that
right I am we'll be streaming at like 2
A.M I think you and I I think so really
I we did it last time for T we had that
we got to come up with a new crap that
was a crappy bet we don't speak of that
bet it all came down to I had like this
new cape on that boost your experience
cuz we were both like popping the
bounties that we had saved up beforehand
and I don't even we we the the BET got
completed in five less than five minutes
I didn't have you buy me a steak I got
you got me like sushi for lunch instead
of a steak because I felt bad about it
gas station Sushi it it felt
anti-climatic very very much so and it
was just like all right cool oh okay
we're done with the vet guys let's go
into the game Yeah by that point I was
coffee crashing at what 2 am I think
same thing launched H anyway that'll be
great yeah are you you don't play
Destiny I remember T King you tried
getting into it a little bit no or back
into it no no wanted to not your thing
like
chores I want to get into Destiny but
it's I you know what it is it's the loot
that I want and I like I like the
gameplay like I played it when it first
came out like even back in the beta and
I enjoyed that but it didn't grab me it
it was just so much of a shooter without
enough narrative and it's better now I
wouldn't I wouldn't say like it's like
oh my God it's like crazy better but
it's definitely a lot it's in a way
better place than it was when you play
man I just need more time at this stage
yeah that's all there is pring too yeah
I know like I'm trible do a segment soon
about like where they go from here with
Destiny 2 or something but I'll be
playing with you get my light level up
to speed before I haven't played in a
while been playing the last couple days
get raid ready when it comes out cuz
there's going to be a spark of light
again to get you yeah but that one you
know like if you haven't playing or if
you want to play a different class or
something like that let's say you've
been playing Hunter but you're like oh I
want to play Titan for uh rise of iron
it'll bring you up to level 40 which is
like Max actual like level level and
then it'll also bring you up to 280
light level which is like you know based
off your gear but you'll get a like
somewhere to start I guess yeah that's
collection though that's the $60 one
cool we kind of kept talking about it so
just close it out again Destiny rise of
irons $30 PS4 Xbox One September 20th
keep an eyle for it all right that's the
end of our show we kind of went long
today but we had a lot of things to talk
about it's so first without
Danny yeah I don't know why that would
make us go along but it did that guy
yeah I'm going to go try to play rocket
League well now destiny I guess not just
kidding I'm getting ready for a rise of
iron playing rocket league in the me
have time for both I got some things I
got to do first gross I don't have
anything to do go to the bathroom I
really evolving really quickly anyway as
always thanks for joining us in the
lobby 2 pm every week here at Gamespot
talk about video games and uh you can
listen to us on iTunes you can Stitcher
uh we'll be around SoundCloud yeah uh so
cool thanks for joining us and until
then we will see you next
[Music]
week